chers amis nous allons commencer chez
qui un peu de files d'attentes en bas la
salle va se remplir au fur et à mesure
comme comme de coutume nous entamons la
dernière ligne droite de nos conventions
thématiques sert de nos demi journée
pour celles et ceux qui viennent
régulièrement vous connaissez par coeur
le format cette demi-journée est
évidemment particulièrement importante
on parle pas d'affaires culturelles sans
évoquer évidemment les questions de
société que que pose au fond
l'intégration et la vision culturelle
d'un d'un pays
puis nous la semaine prochaine nous
aborderons les questions de affaires
étrangères de relations internationales
comment envisager un avenir pour la
france sans savoir prévoir influer sur
l'organisation de l'europe c'est certain
mais du monde c'est évidemment encore
plus certain
la france je peux pas avoir un avenir
hexagonal elle a évidemment un autre
avenir et ils photo intégré tout cela et
puis on terminera par une convention
vers le 20 juin sur les institutions et
puis après nous nous donnerons rendez
vous conseiller national du 2 juillet
pour la production et le vote du projet
alors ce matin on va parler de culture
et de communication
c'est un sujet qui a été traité depuis
des mois préparé par david arguilhé
boutin par par david lisnard par
florence portelli par beaucoup d'autres
je vous remercie par emmanuel hamelin
est plein de personnes qui ont travaillé
tout au fur et à mesure des semaines
pour essayer de bien ça y est le sujet
en général les projets des partis
politiques ou même des candidats se
termine chez renault par un chapitre sur
la culture
une dizaine de lignes des drapeaux
photographie d'une oeuvre d'art ou de
français dans des musées et puis voilà
on a réglé le problème de la de la
culture des politiquement correct de
toujours une hésitation entre cultures
ou europe au dernier
la dernière page on va essayer de faire
différemment parce qu'évidemment on ne
croit pas à cela
on va surtout essayer de le prouver
parce que sinon vous ne croirez pas et
c'est pour ça que cette convention elle
est particulièrement je pense charpente
et autour d'abord de l'éducation
artistique du spectacle vivant
nous pensons que l'éducation artistique
et finalement le commencement de tout
donc on va évoquer cela lors d'une table
ronde présidée par florence portelli qui
vous présentera ses invités et puis
après on passera au aux industries
culturelles
la culture c'est d'abord c'est aussi une
économie
chacun en est d'accord et puis nous
aborderons également la question des
médias notamment du de l'audiovisuel
public est une vraie question quel
avenir pour l'audiovisuel public qu'est
l' organisation quel financement de
l'audiovisuel public quel rapport entre
l'audiovisuel public et l'audiovisuel
privé qu'est l'audiovisuel dans un monde
de plus en plus numérique avec une
influence formation et de contenus qui
passe par beaucoup de canaux et donc
nous parlerons de ceux de ce sujet et
david hervé
boutin présidera cette table ronde et
puis la dernière table ronde sera
présidée par david lisnard que le
festival de cannes maintenant terminé a
pu libérer et qui évoquera les questions
d'attractivité de rayonnement culturel
de notre pays mais aussi de patrimoine
très souvent le patrimoine l'ennemi au
second rang alors que lorsqu'on va sur
les territoires comme on dit la question
de l'entretien
la question du financement du patrimoine
et quelque chose de majeur du très grand
patrimoine avec des modèles économiques
extrêmement sophistiqué jusqu'au
patrimoine le plus modeste qui fait
s'arracher les derniers cheveux des
mères en question qui n'arrivent pas à
financer ce patrimoine et on évoquera
cela donc avec david et l'ensemble de
ses invités comme d'habitude on
terminera vers midi ou à midi avec le
synthèse les conclusions les projets 2
que nicolas sarkozy présentera au titre
des républicains je vous souhaite une
très bonne matinée
elle sera dense et passionnante et je
sais tout de suite et sans tarder la
parole à florence portelli